live
chairman good evening everybody and
welcome to this meeting of the
performance governance and audit
committee on Thursday the 28th of
September
2023 my name is councelor Vanessa Bell
and I am the chair person chairman of
this committee we do just have a few
housekeeping issues to run through
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak and I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
could I ask members to avoid approaching
the top table as this could create
interference with the cameras and live
stream and please note that the YouTube
live stream recording is dependent on
the correct use of the microphones
therefore can I ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn on on your
microphone and turn it off when you
finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and please keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible agenda item two apologies for
absence we have a full house members
tonight which is uh lovely to see so no
apologies so moving on to minutes of the
last meeting so it is recommended that
the minutes of the meeting held on the
27th of July 2023 found on pages 5 to 10
are approved as a true and accurate
record apart from the imaginary people
that apparently attended we did not have
councelor Pratt or councelor stamp at
the meeting we had councelor bound
substituting for councelor Pratt and I
believe cancer stamp was it cancer lagen
for you yes it was are there any other
um any other matters oh sorry I've
skipped forward I I so move do I have a
second yeah thank you answer
something um any other matters of
accuracy from those meeting minutes no
okay so can we agree to those being
correct with the Amendments
stated agreed super thank
you matters Rising oh sorry sorry you
say with the Amendments stated with the
amendment stated
yes I did say that didn't I what me
sorry can I just yes sorry councelor
Pratt and councilor Stan were not
attending attending at the meeting and
um councelor B and councelor lagen were
there
instead thank you very much super thank
you item four it's recommended that the
matters arising from the minutes of the
meeting held on 27th of July found on
pages 11 to 12 are noted are so move do
I have a seconder thank you councelor
okay do we agree members by sent y
lovely thank you item five disclosure of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests I always struggle with that
other registerable interests and non-reg
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
9 and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members and members are reminded
that they're also required to disclose
any such interest as soon as they become
aware should the need arise throughout
the meeting any Declarations of Interest
members no
marvelous and we have no public
participation under item six as far as I
understand am I correct comme Club
that's correct yes lovely thank you okay
so that brings us on to item seven which
is review of corporate performance for
quarter 1 and you can find this on pages
13 to
52 I shall hand over to Miss Hughes to
present the report Miss Hughes whenever
you're ready thank
you thank you uh so following a new
corporate plan for molden being adopted
on the 22nd of February
2023 this is the first time the
committee is seeing the rebuild of the
corporate performance reporting to
reflect the new key performance
indicators also known as kpis which have
been mapped to delivery some of the
performance indicators are under
development but the performance
specialist has worked hard to complete
this rebuild for quarter one making sure
that we report back to keep to the PGA
schedule and the report follows the
draft that the committee members fed
back in on the 20th of June Workshop
session the data presented refx quarter
1 which is April to June
2023 section 3.1 of the covering report
which is found at page 13 of your agenda
pack highlights the high level view for
each corporate
priority at this stage work for all
priorities is broadly on track but there
are conditional Elements which are
flagging in the themes of supporting our
communities enhancing and connecting the
place and smarter
finances the full set of kpi data is
then set out in appendix one which is
found on pages 15 to 15 to 52 of your
agenda packs and that's what informs the
priority views members are invited to
review and feedback on the corporate
performance report and confirm Assurance
of effctive Performance Management
thanks thank you any other officers wish
to
comment no okay so the
recommendation
um is found on page 13 and that is
little one that members review the
information as set out in this report in
appendix one with priority Focus given
to the Strategic priority level
performance little too that members
confirm that they are assured through
this review that corporate performance
is being managed effectively I so move
do I have a second thank you
I could already see councelor STS and
councelor stamps hands shoot up
so over to
you okay um thank you madam chair I
would just like to say how nice this
new um performance um thing looks um
thing thing sorry um I'm glad it's not
just me it's a long day it's been a long
day it it is an awful lot clearer um
than what we've had before and it
actually is easier to read um I'd also
like to draw people's attention to page
30 and on page 30 we talk about the
tourism um and the tourism group has
successfully secured funding to deliver
an intern internal project um I believe
that that was the walking Festival that
actually was greatly received and was
really really good so I would like to um
express my thanks to uh Miss cable and
Miss cordless um for all the work that
they put into arranging that so thank
you thank you I'd like to Echo that I
mean from from everything I've heard it
was an absolutely superb event so
absolutely brilliant thank you thank you
councelor still councelor stamp yeah
thank you totally agree with the forms
my eyes are not suffering like they
normally do after looking at things no
seriously I do have problems with them
and that's why they've worked really
hard with us to to do the colors and
everything um my query is on page
48 uh Miss green has normal I'm going to
ask where is she is she here she's here
I knew you I thought I'd seen you um um
the phone inquiries the channel source
for inquiries it says about the the
phone 8% to uh
26248 people who phone do we know these
are the inquiries that have been
successfully dealt with do we know the
ones that possibly get fed up and put
the phone down um before they get a
response do you do you record that data
please um thank you chairman yes we do
um the system records that um there is a
a very small number of abandoned calls
and that can be for a number of reasons
um so sometimes it's because we have
pre-recorded information and so the
customer after hearing that um May well
hang up um they man excuse me they may
transfer to an automated telephone
line um equally they may hang up because
they don't want to wait but when we look
at the response times um our response
times are very very low at the moment so
the the numbers of customers that will
be hanging up as a result of the length
of time will be of a very small number
of course thank you thank you so do you
record that data is that somewhere on uh
behind the um on a different form or
different SharePoint or how this Council
records the actual exact data um because
sadly this Council actually well this
Council actually sent us all a a link to
do a data LGA course and that was
actually one of the things that was
raised and I thought rather than it go
to waste let's actually just use what
we're being taught and ask the relevant
questions so is there a system that we
operate within this Council that records
to that level of information that can be
accessed if needs to be accessed because
we don't want the data
skewed now absolutely so any calls that
are abandoned are separately
identified and may we have that
information in some format please so yes
the data is recorded and yes it is
available and yes we can share that
marvelous thank you very much thank you
any other questions or um yes Council
bwood just um comment on page 18 under
supporting our communities that first
section there I don't know if it's just
me but some kprs are still to be started
plans however plans in place it just it
does that read right doesn't read right
to me but anyway um what I'm really
interested in is the next bit down it
says the uh start things we started in
September there's a couple of comments
there just interested to find out
whether they have actually been started
thank you thank you it's use I think
that's
is it that to
you I think um either Leandra or PA
might be more informed on that
particular activity the um is that the
youth engagement
program yes that's right yeah yeah uh I
I know there are some um qu uh
challenges around officer um
availability at the moment so I'm not
sure what level of assurance we can
provide around that starting in
September
yes Leander thank you sorry Miss cable
sorry thank you that's no problem um so
I do have an update from the officer um
who's out the office at the minute um so
the youth engagement program is being
delivered in partnership with sexu
service at present we have we support to
deliver the program at oron rivers and
plume Academy that's both secondary
schools in the district the program will
be launched in October 2023 so works
well underway to begin the delivery of
that um will be delivered on a bonly
basis it will aim to provide students in
the local area with opportunities to
engage with the community and make a
positive difference the program is open
to all students at both schools and they
can choose to participate in a variety
of activities such as support
volunteering in the local communities
attend workshops and training sessions
on topics such as health and well-being
Community safety safety and climate
change and organizing and running their
own projects and events in the community
with the support of essics Youth service
at the end of the engagement program the
vision is to create a modern District
Youth Forum which will be a way for
young people to have aane decisions that
affect their lives and to make a
positive impact on their
communities thank you I'm just going to
come in there if I may um because my
understanding is this this has kind of
come out that there is no longer um the
Essex Forum the youth strategy group and
that this is somehow a more local
replacement for that so I'm really
hoping that all the work and all the
young people that were engaged as as
part of that program won't be lost
because we had a huge amount of
Engagement from young people across the
district in that and I'm hoping that
that won't disappear and that we don't
find ourselves having to reinvent the
wheel so I will be talking to and I'm
now having that name thing where I can't
remember her name the youth
commissioning officer councelor St
you'll
know does cable help me out Lauren
Lauren Lauren Lauren Green that's right
yeah so um and rest assured youth is one
of my main areas of Interest so I'll be
making sure that um that happens did you
want to come back I've got you councelor
Sam did you want to come back yes please
um you say it's it's it's mainly
revolving around the plume and uh orston
Academy what happens with all those
young people who are in with other
schools across the district because as
we know School places in the district
are rare and people are being shipped
out left right and Center I want to make
sure it's not just for the the children
or the young people at those
schools I mean I know certainly the
previous work involved a lot of detached
youth work and various other programs
things like skateboard and BMX activity
days so I'm hoping we'll have the same
sort of um things available will we miss
cable I can ask Mr fure for an update on
that and circulate members of course um
Council bwood we do have lots of
neighbor in schools that um people
either choose to send their um stud
children should I say their student
their children their children too so um
as part of inclusive offer I can speak
to Mr Fortune asking to provide an
update on that specific aspect for you
thank you and I'm very keen that we
include what what I referred to as hard
to reach young people who are perhaps
not in school who perhaps looked after
those young people that wouldn't
necessarily be engaging through the
formal Channel we need to be looking at
for provision for them as well so just
one final Point schools are very scary
places for lots of young people to go
into even for a fun activity so we need
to make sure that some of this activity
is not just delivered within the schools
but externally absolutely councelor
bwoods um councilor stand please can I
just declare an interest as an ESS
County councelor we're actually looking
at because ESS County Council has um
doesn't no longer support the youth
service as it did um we are actually
looking at our district with councelor
Durham
and councelor Fleming we are actually
looking at engaging with I think the
gentleman's name is Roy to deliver some
of the what we call is the Urgent uh
subjects that need to be covered um
because they go in and they do the um
knife crime and all that sort of things
so we're we're at the moment um Madam
chair putting a package together that we
can support from an esss County
council's point of view to fund it but
it is going to go to those schools it
isn't going to go as far as I'm aware I
can ask Roy because that's the proposal
we're at the moment trying to put
together but they delivered it last year
when it came under Essex umbrella very
very it was well received welled and
we've also asked if it could be
considered the younger age group as well
because it always seems to focus on is
it year 10 and 11s and I think nowadays
we only have to look what's going on in
society and I think we need to be
preparing certain elements of these um
programs they put on for the for the
other children but I will raise your
point and I think it's an excellent one
at the next meeting we have regarding
the possible funding so thank you
perhaps councelor stamp you and I could
talk separately about this because you
know it's an area of uh interest and
concern for me and I will say again that
since 2010 we have seen a
73% cut in youth service
73% since 2010 we all know what happened
then moving swiftly on any more um any
more questions
or lovely okay that's brilliant thank
you well thank you very much for that
that's
really really helpful so um can we agree
members by sent to that lovely thank you
very much so that brings us on to agenda
item eight which is review of corporate
risk quarter 1 you can find this on
pages 53 to 70 and Miss Hughes you're
very busy this evening it's over to you
again thank you so this report covers
the first quarter of
232 2324 which is April to June 2023 and
the corporate risks appendix one which
is found on pages 55 to 69 of your
agenda packs gives the Full Table of
corporate risk register as at June
2023 section 3.2 of the covering report
shows you where risks have changed
Direction since quarter 4 there is one
risk which has had a rating decrease
since quarter fall and that's R7 failure
to maintain a 5-year supply of housing
Land There is one risk where closure is
recommended which is R2 9 failure to
deliver Services as a result of
covid-19 there are no emerging or
anticipated additional risks to report
this
quarter members are asked to review the
risk register update and confirm
Assurance through this that corporate
risk is being monitored
effectively thank you very much missuse
would any other officers like to
speak no super okay so the
recommendation is that members review
the corporate risk register in appendix
one and provide comment and feedback for
consideration that members review
progress of the corporate risk
mitigating actions in appendix 2 and
provide comment and feedback for
consideration that members are assured
through this review that corporate risk
is being managed effectively and that
members challenge risk where the
committee feels that the council's
corporate plan may not be achieved I so
move do I have a
second thank you councelor Samson I will
throw the floor open now for questions
and comments yes please councelor
spencley
thank you chair um so uh I'm referring
to risk r10 which is Page 64 it would be
interesting perhaps to drill down into
this data in the future because the
economic activity
75.9% about 5% lower than the the East
average and um I'm just wondering where
that falls I check the definition of the
measure and it's economic it's working
age people 16 to 64 if I'm correct um so
I'm wondering what the picture is for
molden and whether youth unemployment is
part of that picture which I think is
unlikely because I get the feeling that
local businesses struggle to recruit
staff but I I just would like to perhaps
in the future see a bit more uh detail
as you yourselves explore that CU I can
see it's a work in progress yes thank
you thank you would any officers like to
come back or comment on
that okay well we'll uh yes thank you
C I can provide it a bit of brief
context um sometimes the specific
details into what makes up those figures
isn't available as in student looking
after home family temporary sick
long-term sick because the figures would
be classified as disclosive by its
nature or a small District um um and
those numbers are relatively small um in
the area and Nomis who are part of on
Define it as disclosive if they were to
break those numbers down
specifically sorry that's helpful thank
you members any other
members yes councelor s only really that
some of them have been on this risk
register for God knows how long and um I
know it's really tricky and and we are
low resources and there's always some
reason why we're not achieving the
targets or the risks are not really
decreasing um but yes the the R7 page 63
which is the fiveyear land Supply I I'm
a little bit cautious of that because I
still don't think that has been tested
at appeal yet so yes at the moment we've
got it and I'm sure at some stage it's
going to be tested at appeal to see if
our methodology and if they W working it
out the people with all the money like
the developers when they take us to uh
uh an appeal win or not um the failure
R15 page 57 the failure to plan a
delivered balance budget over the medium
term could I actually ask for an update
on how uh
from this the temporary section1 officer
or yes sorry Miss Lucas I'm dreadful for
I'm tired been at County I do apologize
having a bit of trouble with names this
evening thank you I do apologize members
and officers um actually how that is
actually going and if it's traveling in
the right direction to be able to meet
that
challenge Miss L
please
sorry thank you chair um thanks
councilor stamp yeah so um I'm I know
you asked for this RK to be updated at
the last um meeting so we have provided
an updated context in terms of the work
that's being undertaken to um mitigate
that risk um as you say that is an
ongoing process
um but the finance member group has met
on several occasions since um the last
meeting and that work is underway um and
will be reported back um to the next
rest resources committee thank you thank
you m MERS Council stand um thank you
madam chair could I actually ask how how
it's going to be reported because we all
know this Council for the past few years
of all we've done is salami slice to
actually try and reach the targets um to
reduce a a service whether it be reduce
a public convenience in Burnham and
molden or whatever so how you actually
being able to or is this group com
coming up with suggestions or the
council coming up with suggestions that
says if you do it this way this is
what's going to happen and if you do it
that way and it's all going to be risk
and it's all going to be measured so
when it comes to the council whether it
comes to strategy and resources or the
um budget meeting I can't remember which
which order it goes in so forgive me so
the the members are actually fully
informed on the decisions they're going
to make because to actually achieve a
budget which we're trying to achieve is
going to be very very difficult I think
we all know that so I I do think members
not everybody enjoys looking at figures
and not everybody understands them so I
think a lot of work needs to go behind
the scenes to present and educate
members uh and I had a suggestion and I
don't think it's been taken up but I do
actually get used to things not being
taken up um but I think it should be
important that members are given a
briefing from last year's accounts and I
think that should be given it's
voluntary so if members want to attend
but I would say it would be really
interesting and helpful to them to go
through I think it's 37 or 39 Pages the
end of year accounts I can't remember um
but to go through it so members have got
an understanding of how a council works
and what it actually means because it's
it's very difficult to understand Madam
chair if you don't understand the
concept of figures cuz some people enjoy
English poetry engineering in and they
don't necessarily understand spelling
yeah well I'm rubish all that but um but
I just think it's a thing to think about
because we wanting all members to work
together but if they don't understand
they don't understand and it's not their
fault thank you thank you very much is
that something we can look at yeah
through you chair thank you um yeah so
as part of the member training group we
have um said that committed to doing
some member training around finances and
one of the sessions that we're planning
would be around sort of understanding
the financial statements and accounts
and more detail um yes that is an
important part of of um understanding
Council finances um obviously the budget
setting process and the sort of
understanding of the management accounts
if you like is a slightly different um
approach or concept to understand but
yeah I take on board the comment and
yeah we have got some training plan
thank super thank you councel STS please
well thank you I was just going to back
what uh councilor stamp said so thank
you for that Miss Lucas um especially as
we have an awful lot of new members on
the council this year that may not be as
of with some of the things as some of
the old members so I think it's
important thank you very much Council
toson please thank you chairman um yeah
I agree with councilor stamp and
councelor stils and that's um I think
you can't beat Education and Training
but um I think we also need members to
understand that we can't keep enhancing
some of Services no matter how much we'd
like to um and no matter how much some
of our residents would like us to I mean
other than for reasons of support for
people who don't have options we just
can't keep enhancing
Services um at the expense of the
majority of the district I I just uh
there's only one way to keep the budget
under control and we can't just alarmy
size we also have to not look for ways
to spend money thanks difficult choices
to make moving forward
members so um are we oh yeah Council
stand before we one more I just want to
say I'd like to thank well all the
officers because they work really hard
but um affordable housing I forgot his
name John swords johs John swords if you
look at risk r33 page 60 uh 61 um his
small team and they are a small team
work really hard to provide um social
and temporary housing uh we was at a
meeting today at County and there was on
about their their building for special
to put people in um Assisted Living Etc
so they're trying to meet their need
that way but I just think it's really
quite nice to say Well done keep it up
we think it's that they've got a really
difficult job um to try and meet the
needs of our ever growing and we've also
and I've said this before we are going
to have to accommodate refugees people
who are coming from you know abroad in
hardship you know coming from water on
countries Etc doesn't matter what your
political view or stand is they're still
human beings and I I think really we
need to as a council be looking at
supporting John swords and his team
about how that can be achieved because
that risk has been on here for as long
as I can remember and I don't think I've
seen that it's changed so all officers
work hard but I think you know we have
to be really careful on this thank you
thank you I have to say I have a lot of
dealings with um Mr swords and his team
and I found them to be absolutely
exceptional I've worked with a number of
local authorities and a number of
housing departments and we are very very
fortunate indeed to have Mr swords and
his uh his offices back yes of course
and then I'll come to you Council I did
say everybody yeah I
know yes and you
Mr thank you what what actually got to
say
was thank thank you members for the you
know of recognition of of the work in
that area but I think it raises a point
around the the risks and you know we
work hard to mitigate all of the risks
but we're not going to eliminate those
risks you know they are corporate risks
and they're they're they're major major
risks but you know I'd pay tribute to
the work done on around the the
temporary accommodation it's it's a
crisis across the country and the fact
that we're our situation is isn't
worsening as much as it might is is you
know to be commended for the for the
work that's being done thank you thank
you councilor bur would you had a
question thank you um being one of those
newer members um there's a lot of things
on here which some of the older members
May will excuse
me have got a lot more knowledge about
because they've been on for a long time
I think it would be really useful if
they were dated when they went onto that
register because it also then highlights
the fact that it's there month after
month or quarter after quarter so I'd
really like to see that because that
would then really sharpen the the focus
if it's the if we see it's been there
for several years thank you I think
that's a really good suggestion I'm sure
that's one we can incor incorporate and
use in the reporting is it I mean as Mr
D said there are some there are some
items that will always be there because
that is the nature of the beast but that
would be helpful if we could certainly
on the ones that we can look at you know
eliminating yeah yeah we'll look at um
including when they were added to the
corporate risk register where possible
super thank you very much members can we
wo counc St one more for one more thank
you I was just going to say when I was
the chair of pgna what was that
2020 I think R7 was on the list then so
it's been on for a long long time thank
you for some context there that's
helpful thank you members can we agree
the recommendations by sen do you need
me to go the recommendations again no
agreed super so I think that brings us
on to agenda item nine annual governance
governance statement
update Y no one's telling me I've lost
myself so uh Miss Hughes is still on
screen so that's on pages 71 to
74 so Miss Hughes over to you again
please yes so at the um 27th of July
meeting of the performance governance
and audit committee the annual
governance statement for 23 uh 2223 was
signed off as well as commenting on our
governance arrangements for last year
this document also identified further
actions around best practice governance
and best practice for governance that we
could Implement in
2324 uh so section 3.5 of the report
provides a table of those actions and an
update of progress as at the end of June
two actions are highlighted at the
bottom of the table in Gray to show that
they've already been completed and
reported as complete and there's a
further seven actions that are ongoing
for the year um that all have an update
text that's been provided for members uh
members are asked to review these
actions and challenge where
necessary thank you very much Miss
Hughes so um yep the recommendation as
Miss H said that the committee reviews
the annual governance statements table
and updates and challenges where
necessary I so move I'm looking at
you thank you seconded by councelor
Thompson um members yes councelor
SS thank you I was just um looking at
page so I've gone down the page page
73 and we talk about um launching and
management e-learning to staff and we're
saying only 133% of Staff have completed
this um can we know why that it's only
133% of the staff that have completed it
and does that also include the
e-learning that the um counselors have
had to do as well which I know that the
um cyber management is one of them that
we've all had to take part so has that
been
included thank you m Hughes can
you yeah so um this training reles
specifically to risk management
e-learning so it's a new module as a
result of the new um risk policy that
was adopted this year it's a new module
that we put in place um and sent out to
all staff um it's uh the 133% I'll have
to check the dates and I can send an
email around to the committee about the
dates but uh we haven't long launched it
when that 13% um so I can give an update
on the latest percentage and when it was
launched um but we are doing reminder
emails to the staff that haven't yet
completed their risky learning but um
quite often with a a new training module
but see takes a little while and a few
reminders um to get
bance thank you very much is does that
lovely thank you any other points or
questions yes councelor s can I just
have an explanation or if somebody can
um yeah explain to me when it says roll
out new service plan template and share
points structure monthly highlight
reports to underpin 2327 corporate plan
reading that obviously it's new it's
only just been started because we've
only just adopted the corporate plan is
that across the board because they says
that's is that for the service team so I
presume we have one
for uh Mr dodson's and M uh Mr Holmes's
teams director so to speak so is is that
what that means sorry what page canel
page 72 thank you so what I'm actually
asking is that when the corporate plan
obviously has been adopted which is what
we have H is it been all the work has
been noted behind the scenes and and
this is what's going to produce these
reports in future do you know what I
mean are you going to come back on
that yeah so as our as part of our
annual cycle this year we've launched a
new mechanism um where um we have eight
service plans so The Individual Services
have their own service plan and that
identifies how they're going to
contribute to delivery of the corporate
plan um and it also identifies kpis so
when um we go through things like the
balance scorecard exceptions the data
for that comes within the service plans
and so those service plans are the
activity that's then driving the
corporate performance reporting that's
coming back to members as well um and
it's all part of that golden corporate
golden thread so it's that you know
you've got the corporate plan we've got
service plans about how we deliver and
then each member of staff's got their
individual smart objectives about how
they contribute to their service plan um
so that it all buils up and down thank
you does that yes you want to come back
that's excellent because I know um um we
I think I attended a couple of meetings
and there were scrums or scums scrums
not scrums sorry
scums you know what I meant but long
time when they first started a few years
ago whatever when I was at leer and they
were really good so that's me was a a um
I'm so struggling with my words it's
like a benchmark so it's actually so
both sides of the director are being
measured on the same terms is it so so
you've got some program behind that you
know if we wanted as a a member to say
how is that report being produced um
there is has actually been um behind the
scenes as I call because I'm a bit of a
a person to like to know the information
dig
deep because it's really important that
that that information is being given so
if somebody does want to drill down to
the data and I know some people like it
to be high level and others don't but I
think for this corporate plan to be a
success and that golden thread we heard
about and every time we SP speak about
the golden thread about the corporate
plan it's a golden thread um but as long
as that's been managed and it's been
reported I presume the directors and
waiting for a nod would sign these
things off would they or whatever and
it's it's actually been a success is it
that's all I'm asking do you want to
come back
Mr yes those those service plans were
all put in place as per you know what
was set out in the corporate plan and
the the golden thread so all of those
service plans were delivered and and as
you know Miss Hugh said they they feed
into the um the smart objectives of all
of the the staff but also the there are
highlight reports for each of those
service plans each month which come
through to CLT so that if there are
there are issues with the delivery or
decisions that me need to be be made to
uh remove any um barriers to delivery
you know it gives us that route to have
a good overview of of everything that's
going on in terms of the delivery of the
corporate
plan of course yeah because I think
that's really important then that that
all those decisions and any problems are
being done before it comes to members so
if people like me was a pain can turn
around and ask the question you go yes
cancer stamp it's already been done x y
and Zed which you know I think it's
important for members to be able to ask
that sort of level of detail thanks
super thank you very much members can we
move forward and agree this by please
that's great agreed thank you very much
now I believe I'm on agenda item
10 see making sure you're all keeping
you all on your toes members just uh
checking that you're focusing so that's
the balance scorecard exceptions report
which you'll find on pages 75 to 9
6 and yet again Miss Hughes over to you
please so uh this report details the
areas of operational performance where
we're seeing exceptions um and that
covers both Under and Over performance
internally the leadership team monitor
this data and discuss it monthly to help
address Performance issues in real time
where possible and then a six- monthly
report is provided to this committee to
show exceptions
this report covers January to June
2023 so section
3.4 um of your report shows a table of
underperforming areas and the actions
that are being taken around these and
section 3.5 highlights two indicators
where we are over
performing section 3.6 also shows an
area where closer monitoring is taking
place at the
moment members are invited to review and
comment on the report and confirm
assurance that operational performan is
being managed effectively and in closing
I also want to highlight that there's a
just a note really that on page 95 of
your agenda papers within the planning
statistics there is a planning appeal
here that's marked as decided by
Southeastern planning committee but it
was actually a district planning
committee decision um so that error will
be corrected and changed in future
reporting and so I just wanted to note
that that's an error in the papers many
thanks Miss and thank you for
highlighting that that's really helpful
thank you so yeah the recommendations
little one that the committee review and
comment on exceptions to service
reporting provided in this report little
two that members note the additional
performance in appendix one little three
that members confirm that they are
assured through this review that
operational performance is being managed
effectively I so move and I have a
secondary and counselor Thompson thank
you very much
members answer
Sals yeah I just want to question page
75 um the reviews of benefits and revs
uh and the time taken and it says
although a decrease seen in processing
time in May previous month saw a steady
um time increase due to system issues
have those system issues been re
resolved and have those um that time
actually increased rather than keep on
decreasing and it might be Miss green I
think yeah I'm not sure whoever whoever
wants to have a go at that Miss green
thank you thank you members yes I'm
pleased to say the system um issues have
been resolved and it was at a time when
just after we send the C tax bills out
that our residents had lots of changes
of circumstances as well so we have an
increase in work so that coupled with
assistance issues did cause us an issue
however I'm pleased to say that we are
back on track and as of the end of
August we're at 7.6 days that's good
news thank you very much Mrs Green thank
you C St I do apologize members but um
I'm I'm interested in page 76 human
resources and sickness data um obviously
this Council I can't remember how many
years ago the sickness level was
brilliant it's really low everybody
worked really hard and there was hardly
any sickness I think it was I can't
remember it just postco I can't remember
now um I am concerned with this but I
also know it's a national issue it's not
just an Ethics issue it's not just a
modern District issue um but what are we
doing to to safeguard and look after our
staff
because obviously some people when it's
been debated uh especially members of
the public will say well hang on a
minute a lot of them were working from
home why are they getting stressed they
don't have to go in the office they
haven't got all those sort of challenges
um like what they used to have um and I
know I've certainly been an advocate and
saying I think a lot more work should
come back into the office but then
that's not my decision but there are
reasons for saying that so what are we
doing to help and Safeguard our team is
it because they're overworked and
overstressed is it because we don't have
the
resources uh what is it thank you thank
you councilor stamp who would like to
come back I cons sense Mr doson thank
you thank you chair um yes the
the uh sickness level and sickness rate
has gone up at this Council as it has
nationally as as you you noted um and it
is disappointing the level that it's at
it did come down to to virtually zero at
one point which I think
was wildly unusual more so more so than
the figure being um where it is now it's
some something that we work um really
hard on both from a perspective of
supporting staff and you know we put the
the work in around the the mental health
support that we do particularly if
people you know are experiencing stress
through work and and in terms of the
working within the office the office is
always available you know it's we don't
instruct people to work at home we have
a flexible working policy and those that
want to work in the office can work in
the office and obviously Some people
prefer the the uh environment of the
office um and and there are issues with
with loneliness and isolation which
which we make sure that we're addressing
through you know the regular one to ones
we have in St with staff Etc we do also
have the the welfare package that that
covers all staff so that there is
support through for any staff that are
going through difficulties as well and
that's available 247 throughout the the
year and people are referred to that um
we obviously have the um the
occupational health support you know if
people need to be um referred into that
so there's a whole range of of support
that is available um I would note that
the figures are slightly skewed we do
have um a handful of cases of long-term
sick at the moment and in a small
organization that that soon pushes your
your figures up so we're working closely
with those staff that are affected um
through that to support them through the
issues they're facing and back into work
and probably finally worth saying
alongside all of the support we offer um
we do run a a Bradford score system
which does highlight when people um are
off sick you know if if they go over
certain days or certain incidences of
sick it Flags it to the line manager and
it triggers a a meeting we do meetings
anyway when people come back from any
time off SI they have a return to work
interview however if their Bradford
score goes higher it triggers to have a
conversation for the manager to to fully
understand what's what's the cause of
that you know it might be somebody's
just caught a cold twice in in six
months and and had to have a few days
off at a time but it it helps us outline
any underlying issues and support staff
with those through the the packages that
I I highlighted thank you very much Mr
Dudson would you like to come back do
you think there's any correlation
because we are underst staffed uh we
haven't got a full full team um with
with sickness it's putting more pressure
on the actual full-time staff cuz we've
maybe got contractors in good
question I wouldn't have evidence of
that
or no I I I wouldn't I wouldn't you
can't just no no I wouldn't say that
like like you say I couldn't
substantiate thank you any other members
wish to comment I'm going to go to
councelor Pratt you haven't spoken yet
and then councelor still good evening sh
um just to come back on what Mr Dodson
says it's it's an Old Chestnut to hide
behind long-term
sickness um could we not
therefore if you took the long-term
sickness away would you be well under
the wire or just under the wire because
I think long-term sick is always
mentioned when we review these things um
would it be beneficial to members and
yourself if you actually showed the two
a this is the story as it is because
this is how we report it if we were to
take the long-term sick out this is
where we would be I think that would be
beneficial to us if we were made
aware would that be fairly easy to
extrapolate Mr it's certainly something
we can go away and look at and I can't
imagine that that would be too difficult
to come up with those those figures if
you could thank you and if I could come
back that wasn't really my question but
just booing on counil remk but
again another Old Chestnut is Miss bins
and on page
77 um in the explanation it says overall
this is this is less than
0.005% sort of saying why are we
worrying about this but if it's an SLA
then we certainly are my concern is not
the number but somewhere in that
information should be the repeats
repeats yeah if you only get your bin
Miss once a year you shrug and you say
that's life but if it's the third time
that your bin has been missed then it's
a problem and it finishes up in in our
emails and saying most certainly does
counil mainly I would like somewhere in
this report for the future to actually
say are there any repeats because it
used to be certainly in the rural areas
up the up the difficult Lane they skip
past it they don't bother and I used to
get emails saying this is the fourth
time in succession that I've not been
collected I'm now taking it down the tip
can I have me money back please so yeah
can we just change the report for the
future please we have a particular issue
in Burnham with parking and there's one
particular Road where many many many
many times someone's Parts on the corner
in the bin Lorry can't get down it so
I'm absolutely agree there is that back
to ah yes Miss sweety please thank you
yeah I got to speak that's lovely um yes
we can absolutely report on that's no
problem at all we do go back or while
the sewers go back within two working
days where there is a report of a missed
bin um but certainly for those repeats
we can report on that yeah super thank
you very much council's done I'd like to
congratulate the bin people actually no
no disres one thing because I think
that's quite good you know to say how
many houses and you chairs raised about
parking and not being able to get down
uh I know that I think you've invested
in smaller bins bin lores because that I
think that was a there was an issue with
a real big issue for B Miss bin
collections but on the whole I don't
have as many pro emails now I if
canc I don't get as many I used to so
I'd like to congratulate them as well
because they do get a lot of um stick
back thank you I'd like to Echo that as
well thank you very much members can we
agree that no no councilor yeah are were
you agreeing or were you commenting no
no no I did have my hand up before and
you did say I go to cancel St um mine
was going to be partly about the misbin
because it said there there was 360 and
234 of those were
Justified so what does it mean by not
justified also could we we also look at
the um the ones where we actually
collect the
household um what was I say potato
peeling type the the the food waste ones
because I know that I've had to report
at least two or three times my neighbors
one being missed so um can we look at
those as
well yes that's that's absolutely fine
um we do have weekly figures for Miss
Ben and um we accept that there has been
some staff turnover within sewers which
is why there's been miss bins and they
do tend to be the food waste that are
missed um so your first question
question councelor it says sorry it says
that 360 were missed but only 234 were
Justified yes so um Justified is where
it was LE left out in the correct um
area uh we do sometimes have reports of
M bins where um it's an additional bin
it's not been left out it could be a
commercial waste bin so those are ones
that would not be justified so we do
have to look into those and investigate
them but where it is a Justified Miss
bin then they do go out with within
those two working
days thank you if if we could report
something like thatwe could you pop your
microphone up just if we could report
something like that that would be great
because then we could actually see
especially it was commercial and that so
that would give us an idea I do have one
other question and it'll be from Miss
green I think it says areas of contact
us over due cases 164 cases as of 30 in
June um are we actually looking at
getting that decreased I know it says
that whilst a decrease of overdue cases
has been seen in the last 6 months
approximately 50% of those outstanding
are pre 2023 so can we have an update on
that place thank you over to you Mrs
Green um thank you chairman so the
contact us forms are um inquiries that
are made and and those are triage so are
customer services team will try to
answer them initially and then they will
be triaged through to the um to the
various services so those will cover a
range of of different service areas as
as the report says there has been some
strong work on the housekeeping of those
um there is still more to do but there
has been some good work and quite a lot
of the inquiries um the older ones are
likely to have been responded to but
just not closed off on the system so
that's what that housekeeping working is
there to to to finish the up and yes
good progress is being made on those
super thank you does that yeah that's
that's great thank you and I'd like to
thank all the officers for their hard
work that they put into this absolutely
thank you very much and I'd like to
apologize for forgetting you there
councelor stilts because I did to have
you on my list me no it wasn't members
can we agree that by aent
please lovely thank you very much and
now we really are on the agenda item 11
review of health and safety quarter 1
and um
unfortunately um Mr bini hasn't made it
so or has he there oh he has there you
are yes there you are lovely to see you
remotely Mr bini um so I'm going to pass
over to you to present the report
please thank you good evening chair yes
I present the health and safety uh
statistics and key from quarter 1 uh
starting on page 97 I believe in the
report of the accidents and instance
shown in section
3.1.1 there were three all a low level
one involved a member of the public
however this was an unsubstantiated
report involving a minor
injury of the incidence of unacceptable
behavior shown in section 3.1.2 we had
five reports including one refer from a
partner organization regarding dangerous
animals one of the unacceptable Behavior
incidents was received in person by a
member of the waste
cruise this was a threat of violence and
was referred to the
police there have been no particular
Trends in accidents or incidents in the
period or in reports of unacceptable
Behavior detected but these will
continue to be
monitored of the health and saf
actions work continued on the main
themes the table is presented in 3.2
given a summary of
these draft policies on first aid and
personal evacuation were
completed work on revising the existing
policy on unacceptable behavior is
continuing this will also involve work
on the reporting system used uh by
officers um to make their reports of
unacceptable Behavior
as mentioned in the previous report
forums are due to be established for the
routine discussion of health and safety
in the authority and I believe these
will help improve the focus terms of
reference have been drafted uh and and
these have been put to senior man
managers and they they're due to be
discussed we're only to get the right
mix of day-to-day operational and longer
term strategic issues captured in each
of the for
us finally ongoing inspections of
different departments have commenced
action plans have been devised in
response to two mini audits of the two
Council depos and visits have been
undertaken at the Leisure centers and
way
Depo uh that is the conclusion of my
report and I just note the
recommendations at the
beginning thank you very much Mr barar
find find this very encouraging
particularly the mini audits I think
we're um it feels like we're going in
the right direction with this so thank
you very much so um yeah the
recommendations is the one that members
consider the accident and incident
incident
statistics two that members consider
progress of key health and safety themes
as per section
3.2 and that members consider additional
health and safety improvements being
implemented in addition to those
identified in the main health and safety
themes I so move do I have a second
thank you councelor sson members over to
you yes councelor spencley thank you
chair um thank you for the report um
first of all as a member I'd like to
express sympathy for staff members who
face abuse and aggression I mean nobody
in a public facing role who only wants
to try and help people should have to
tolerate um that kind of behavior um
I've got a specific question about the
house with the dangerous ous animals I
have to say chair my imagination started
to crocodiles C I'll be talking about a
couple of Bengal tigers or half a dozen
Excel bullies um so we got reassurance
that our staff are safe because they're
advised not to visit but this house will
be visited by delivery people Tradesmen
postal workers and the doors might not
be secured uh and I know all this stuff
about dangerous dogs has some of the
trappings of moral panics in the Silly
Season in the summer
nevertheless you know really horrible
things have happened involving dangerous
animals so so can we know what what
animals are involved and if any other
agencies are involved with with dealing
with this are we allowed to be specific
under um data protection about that Mr
Beck good point um I was in this
particular instance I was asked to um
sort of um sanitize that and remove the
reference uh because there is a case
ongoing with one of our partners so um
it's
yeah thank you for that I I did suspect
that might be the case but it appears
action is being taken which is the
important thing so thank you anybody
else no then can we agree by scent
members agreed agreed marvelous thank
you very much Mr bini I'm sorry you got
stuck in traffic and I didn't realize
you'd made it yet thank you thank thank
you okay so that moves us on to um item
12 which is the UK shared and rural
England England Prosperity funds which
is on pages 103 to 108 so it's over to
you Miss cable for this
please thank you and if it's acceptable
to you chair I'll run through um the
items under 3.1 first yes and then we're
we're going to take questions sorry I
actually have that on my prompt and I
completely forgot so yeah we're going to
take a break and um Miss Cable's going
to answer questions after we've reached
3.1.6 because there may be a lot so um
thank you um as members will recall from
the uh last report uh M District
received a million pound allocation from
the UK share Prosperity fund as part of
the government's leveling up allocation
as per the report provided to committee
on the 15th of June due to government
delays a request was sub submitted to
rofile the underspend from 2022 to 2023
to The Current financial year we were
very pleased once this was approved
appendix one of the report sets out the
projects being delivered VI the funding
over the three-year period of which we
have Circa 18 months left and projects
continue to be delivered on time and
with intolerance despite delays in
receiving the funding where projects are
not being progressed du to feasibility
funding will be reallocated to other
existing projects within the investment
plans with the current economic climate
and the cost of doing business
increasing it's prudent to ensure all
projects align to our corporate plan and
deliver its priorities to date at
writing the report Circ £68,000 have
been committed to the progression of
projects and agreed cost for management
and
administration that's the conclusion of
that part thank you so members any
questions um on on the first part of
Miss Cable's
report that's s um yeah forgive me if
I'm got mixed up as usual um so are we
looking at appendix
one we've not looked at appendix one I
just want to know if that's correct
right so has any of the schemes slipped
financially are they still on cost um
financially to be delivered microphones
if you could sorry
that's Council St on now are you
finished yeah oh basically you know what
I'm asking is it on Miss cable on please
thank you all the projects are reporting
um in accordance with what we budgeted
and um as noted in the report on section
3.1.5 where they haven't been feasible
such as the bid feasibility St the bid
feasibility study was unfeasible
um the the funding for that was
reallocated to the supporting local
business program which members will
recognize as a key priority in our
helping the economy to thrive um
priority um in terms of other larger
projects where there is additional costs
that are being incurred we will of
course look at the projects that are
being delivered already within that have
not started but are scheduled to be
delivered with the investment plan um to
ensure that you know the larger um
more high value projects can be
delivered um and where modifications can
be made through sensible discussion with
the officers who are responsible for
delivery then that will be the case for
example if something that's red costs
more in that color maybe we could do it
in pink cuz it's cheaper or something
like that so you still look at the same
product but there's slight
amendments um to perhaps the design or
the material Etc without um that being
of detriment to the project
itself yes C thank you so so for example
I'm going to use a specific project
because it's easier for everybody then
to relate to and I'm going to pick on
one that I know very well which is the
burnam on Crouch pontoon so if that's
because of the way the officers chose to
progress that um project to be delivered
say for example worst case scenario
because I am a bit like a negative nin
sometimes and a bit of a realist if that
is going to come in over budget or it's
not going to be delivered to the same
spec as what we members most probably
was led to believe at the time would
members be consulted again regarding a
rever revised schedule or rever revised
drawing or whatever it's going to be
because what what I think I'm concerned
about a million quid sounds a lot of
money but it's not when you're doing
some big projects and it's very easy to
overrun and I can remember asking at
that particular meeting how how often
has this Council delivered on budget for
any of its projects and the answer I got
was none um and I I did actually ask for
evidence and I've had nothing so forgive
me I'm not saying it is going to overrun
but I'm very cautious because I know how
easily it is in today's economic climate
for projects that most probably going to
be scra scrapped possibly scrapped or
reduced because of uh potential overruns
so can you give us any assurance that
they are being monit sorry chairman but
I think it's we don't want our own hs2
councelor stamp do we so no absolutely
Miss cable would a bit shorter than HS
to yeah hopefully um this cable would
you like to come back on that well I
hope to Buck that Trend and deliver this
project on time all power to your elbow
and um so what we I am doing is working
extremely closely with the officer
delivering this project and have been
involved with meetings um with them
they're going through revised costings
analysis at the minute um with the
Architects that we're working with and
you know beginning that process of you
know the nice to haves versus the
absolute critical musthaves and I
understand there will be award member
briefing coming up shortly um where
those options can can be discussed as
well that's great thank you and can I
just request as always with the big
Burnham um big Burnham projects and
issues that you make it both WS because
we all get the
same the same items in our email inboxes
don't we thank you councelor st thank
you Miss C so if there are no more
questions on the first part I'll go back
to you for part two
please so this part of the report is
slightly longer because I appreciate
some of the newer members won't be as
familiar with the rural England
Prosperity fund as some of our previous
members so the department of environment
food and Rural Affairs defra published
the rural England Prosperity fund
prospectus in September 2022 which came
as a bit of a surprise to all local
authorities the prospectus confirmed
that Moren District Council have been
allocated just over £430,000 to be spent
by March
2025 the rep as it's known is um
integrated into the UK share Prosperity
fund which supports productivity and
prosperity in places that need at most
for eligible local authorities such as M
District Council the rep is a rural top
up to ukpf allocations it supports
activities and specifically addresses
the challenges rural areas faced as
agreed at strategy and resources
committee on the 10th of November
2022 the development of the investment
plan was delegated to the director of
strategy performance and governments in
consultation with the leader of the
council and the chairman of strategy and
resources committee the submitted
investment plan was approved by defa and
cons conf firmed support for under
supporting local business funding in the
form of capital grants for small scale
investment in micro and small
Enterprises and under support supporting
rural e communities funding of capital
grants grants for Rural circular economy
projects and funding for impactful
volunteering and social action projects
to develop social and human capital in
local
places unlike the UK share Prosperity
fund the council does not receive any
additional management and administration
funding to support the delivery but
officers have proactively secured
additional funding from Magno for this
element of the program over a 2-year
period this funding has facilitated the
council in partnering with the rural
community council of Essex and ensuring
organizations and applicants have a
dedicated resource to support them
officers are working with rcce to
develop the eligibility and awarding
criteria for the funding with the
program expected to open in Autumn
2023 brilliant I thank you very much
proactive work going on there as well
which is excellent so the recommendation
is that the committee acknowledges the
update provided on M District's UK
shared and rural England Prosperity fund
allegations and continues to monitor the
delivery I so move thank you seconding
councilor Johson so members over to you
any questions or
comments yes councilor s thank you um
I'd like to say well done I mean because
I think this council's been very good at
getting grants we've always run what's
the old old saying a sour silk purse
sour ear or whatever the old saying is
making a silk you know what I mean don't
you you run a silk you make a
silk yeah and I think this Council
actually does that especially when it
comes to finding grants um and I think
they've done really really well and I
think it might be really nice um in the
future when these have been delivered um
that a presentation is is done to this
committee or whichever committee to say
we've achieved this by doing this um
because yet again I think this was said
at some sort of meeting I don't know
which meeting it was of this Council we
we're all very good at saying what we
don't do well we're very bad at saying
what we do do well and I think this is I
think this is really you know for for
you to be still looking this Council be
looking to get grants to actually
deliver these things on behalf of our
residents maybe do need to be shouted a
little bit more cuz some of us are quite
hard task M maskers and we do ask
difficult questions of you um but I
think you've done really well as long as
you deliver the Pontoon on time and I'm
price no pressure Miss cable there thank
you councelor Stan that anybody else so
are we happy just to oh counc yes of
course thanks Council stamp beat me to
it though you know a well done very
excellent clear report as always and
thank you for the work and thank you for
finding the extra funding where isn't
provided by the other and you know
not not making an extra you know extra
resource needed from our own offices
thank you
absolutely thank you so members thank
you again um Miss cable members can we
agree that by
say super thank you very much which
brings us on to agenda item 13 any other
items of business that the chairman of
the committee decides are Urgent there
are none so at this point I'd like to um
say officers with the exception of poor
Mr butcher always gets The Late Shift um
officers if you wish to leave now please
feel free to do so and thank you very
very much everyone for your
contributions and and for the moral
support of those of you who have not
contributed thank
you okay item 14 to exclusion of the
public and press to resolve the under
Section 100a bracket four of the Local
Government Act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business on the grounds that they
involve a likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph
three of part one of schedule 12a to the
ACT and that this satisfies the public
interest tests I so move do I have a
second thank you councelor Thompson so
um support team if we could have the
live stream off
please